all right our very own Piers Morgan he
sat down for an interview with Stormy
Daniels who of course is at the center
of Alvin Bragg's case against Donald
Trump now Piers asked her if she wants
Donald Trump to go to jail here's what
she said
would it give you any kind of closure
with your time involving Donald Trump to
see him jailed
specific to my case I don't think that
his crimes against me are
worthy of incarceration
okay and Pierce also asked stormy about
this Infamous we've read this many times
we've shown it to you many times uh 2018
letter in which she denied having an
affair with Donald Trump and she signed
their name to it take a look
right some people point to the contents
of this letter and they say well what
changed I mean you couldn't have been
more categoric in saying I was still
under the NDA Michael Cohen wrote that
and had me sign it and I didn't want to
which is why I signed my name wrong
right before I went on Kimmel and
pointed it out how did you sign your
name
it doesn't it doesn't look like my
signature oh I see yeah but you were
still under the NDA so you felt obliged
to do this I was told if I didn't and
they'd sue me for the 20 million dollars
or whatever it was
I had not been released from the NDA
all right here now is Piers Morgan
Pierce welcome to the show good to have
you back
thank you
you know so
I'm a fan uh by the way a great audience
Sean yeah
they're great they love you too
who's there
we'd love to have you all right so and
by the way we used to be competitors you
know he was he once worked at fake news
CNN
uh but you talked about America and guns
and I'm like every time he talked about
guns I'm like yes they don't want to be
lectured by a Brit about our gun laws we
believe in our Second Amendment
um but you're we became good friends and
you know I was thinking about this
because you're in your show's doing
phenomenal you had Donald Trump uh Boris
Johnson I believe you had recently
Rhonda Santos recently BB Netanyahu
recently you go to all those people and
now Stormy Daniels I was a little
surprised but I'm really curious about
this because the issue of an NDA is very
specific that somebody will agree to
accept a certain amount of money and in
exchange they say they will not disclose
whatever the incident is about whether
it's true or not true you know I believe
in the old-fashioned way a handshake is
a deal but I'm old school so did she did
she agree to the NDA or not did you get
that out of her
well I think it's very it's complicated
and it's very interesting and let me
just say at the start that Donald Trump
as I said in the uh in the course of the
interview has always emphatically denied
any affair she has emphatically said
there was one uh and there was of course
undeniably this NDA which was agreed
between them just before the 2016
election so all those things are as they
are but the question is was she released
from that NDA and before she was
released was she compelled to deny the
affair she said very strongly in the
interview that in January 2018 when the
Wall Street Journal Washington Post
whichever one it was broke the story
about this deal that they done before
the 2016 election she said that she was
under pressure from Michael Cohen Donald
Trump's lawyer that she had to go along
with denying any Affair otherwise she
would be in breach of the NDA and she
would have to pay 20 million dollars and
she really believed that so I think
that's probably true the question then
is what happened after that well very
quickly after that she sued to be
released from the NDA and Donald Trump
because he hadn't signed the NDA himself
it was all done by others including
Michael Cohen he actually in that court
process when she sued released her from
the NDA effectively and said like I
didn't sign it and she's no longer and
has to abide by it and on the back of
that she went out and did interviews
including with Anderson Cooper at CBS
and others and Donald Trump to my
knowledge has taken no legal action
against her all those networks as a
result of her talking about what she
says was the affair so that's the
chronology here but what's interesting
Sean I thought my takeaway was what she
then said about this whole case because
it doesn't really matter who you believe
about the affair that's not what this
court case is now about the court case
is about whether there was some kind of
cover-up what the 130 000 was all about
and that is really what that was at the
center of what happened in Manhattan
this week I share your view for what
it's worth that it's a massive overreach
and I think Stormy Daniels shares that
view and she's the woman at the center
of the stormy if you like and I think
she shares the view that this is all a
bit over the top are we really going to
see an American president brought down
and put in prison because of a
relationship you may or may not have had
with a porn star it seems absurd so I
think that putting it all in context
Stormy Daniels is entitled to her her
opinions Donald Trump is entitled to his
emphatic denials but ultimately she
shares the view of what I think is what
most people think which is that this is
a huge overreach going on okay but in
this case in Manhattan here's there is a
timeline problem and the timeline is
this she signs the NDA fine the election
happens the allegation is Donald uh
Trump wanted Michael Cohn to do this
even though Michael Cohen himself a
Michael Cohen's lawyer said they did it
without the knowledge of the Trump
campaign or the Trump organization now
the timeline is he Money Paid to Michael
Cohn listed in the indictment all
happened in 2017. okay so that would
have been after this Michael Cohen
agreement with stormy but the problem
for them then becomes 2018 in February
when Michael Cohen's lawyer writes a
letter to the FEC saying that the Trump
organization the Trump campaign had
absolutely nothing to do with this deal
this was between Michael and stormy so I
think they got a big timeline problem do
you see that
well listen it's very complicated
there's no question no it's not that
complicated
in 2018 they denied any payment was ever
made by the Trump organization or the
Trump campaign yeah
no what I'm talking I'm not talking
about the intricacies of what's happened
in Manhattan I'm talking about the
timeline which is Stormy Daniels sues to
be released on the NDA and Donald Trump
allows her to be released from the NDA
that's the timeline she sticks to as to
why she then came out and was allowed to
speak and I think that's probably
accurate that's generally speaking last
question the timeline you talk about
that's a different issue yeah okay if an
NDA people enter into an NDA should that
be respected in other words you make a
deal you make a decision you sign your
name at that point you accept money
it's why shouldn't that be a valid legal
document
well it absolutely should be and but
bear in mind Sean she did actually win
that case it was dismissed she was
declared the winner in fact all the
money that she owes Donald Trump when
she sued him for defamation actually
some of the money won't be paid because
she's owed that by the Trump side for
the NDA case she fought which she was
actually deemed to be the successor on
so it is complicated and I think she was
entitled to go and tell her story albeit
I don't know if the story that she tells
is the true one all right here's Morgan
you've had some phenomenal interviews
lately uh thanks for sharing it with us
great to see you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else